tout le monde d'ores et déjà commencé à
pêcher vous l'avez reconnu gérard sous
sa petite moustache et gérard de lyon et
gérard collomb l'ex-ministre de
l'intérieur macro nist de la première
heure retourne dans la ville qu'il a
dirigée pendant 16 est né en banlieue
lyonnaise fils d'un ouvrier et d'une
femme de ménage
agrégé de lettres devenu prof voilà pour
le background de gérard collomb sanaa
son passé politique commence en 1981 au
parti socialiste gérard collomb est élu
député de la seconde circonscription du
rhône à lyon donc une modification
complète politique
et oui gérard collomb fait partie de ces
socialistes trentenaire qui dépoussière
les parties véritable première tentative
à la mairie de lyon deux ans plus tard
et voilà comment ils se présentaient à
la télé la fidélité à mes idées
d'enfance et à mon milieu familial on
n'a jamais défaut qu'on déteste je suis
soi même il est disqualifié dès le
premier tour à gérard collomb et c'est
encore en 1989 et c'est un échec
troisième tentative en 1995 sans
moustache cette fois et il est élu maire
du 9e arrondissement
un pas vers la tête de la ville qu'ils
décrochent en 2001 après quatre
tentatives tout de même pour jean macé
c'est l'aboutissement des démarches de
25 ans donc c'est forcément que émouvant
réélu au premier tour en 2008 gérard
collomb à lyon c'est de la culture de
l'urbanisme avec le projet de la
confluence ces villes nouvelles du
laténium celle du tramway du vélo en
libre-service des berges aménagées
c'est l'image de léon qui change et des
points noirs aussi une fiscalité
grandissante et un intérêt trop grand
pour l'international au détriment du
local
16 ans à la tête de l'ue ont jusqu'à ce
que son poulain accède à l'elysée
gérard collomb est nommé ministre de
l'intérieur sauf que moins d'un an et
demi après sa nomination
à 71 ans il retourne à lyon dans une
ville divisée à reconquérir
[Musique]